my next guest slam blm is a scam whose
house of cards may be falling joining me
now is indiana attorney attorney general
rod rakita uh todd rakita excuse me um
attorney general rokita uh you actually
have some news to break on this front
tonight explain
well we're starting an investigation
we're going to find out if this black
lives matter organization which
in indiana we previously defined
legally as a as a political organization
so there's first amendment implications
there uh if you're teaching black lives
matter material in school and other
things but now
uh seeing that this house of cards is
is coming down we want to know
if black lives matter has solicited
funds in indiana
from indiana residents if they have any
real property here
because that all
would invoke
our ability
under our nonprofit
laws
to see if they're being wasteful to see
what their expense ratios are to see if
they're a scam not unlike the one we
unraveled last week where we found
you know someone selling overly valued
silver coins to the elderly i mean at
some point what's the difference here
scams a scam we're gonna find out we're
gonna go where the facts lead us of
course
and if they don't lead us anywhere we're
gonna stop
uh but we suspect this is in fact a
house of cards
yeah now this is this is a huge amount
of money that was raised now last month
the la times profile blm co-founder
patrice cullers and her split from blm
she said that when the larger construct
that you invested in abandons you where
do you go i think that what i'm really
trying to figure out right now
um she's trying to figure out where
she's going to go now this woman walked
away
from running a charity with enough cash
uh that reportedly some say to buy four
homes and then called criticism of this
white supremacy she said she never got a
salary from black lives matter some
money before 2019 but
uh not you know enough to buy
multi-million dollar homes so she
vehemently denied that
but nevertheless when you have really i
think upwards of 100 million dollars in
total raised by
a hashtag
i mean doesn't the government have a
duty to find out where that money went
and how it was spent if it's tax exempt
especially absolutely and again it's
another thing that's falling to the
states and so be it we're gonna we're
gonna pick up this medal and we're gonna
get to the bottom of it you know some of
me laura says you know what a lot of
this money is from woke corporations you
know they get what they deserve but even
those world corporations have
shareholders like me and you
and regular people and and pension funds
and they got to be focused on making a
return for us and not this social gobbly
[ __ ] that leads us nowhere and then what
about the hoosier who uh who who says
who sees black lives matter is like oh
yeah i want to be supportive of that i'm
for equality like we all are and gives
them ten dollars gives them five dollars
gives them whatever
they are they are scamming that person
if in fact that's where this goes
and so we're gonna we're gonna get to
the bottom of it one way or the other
and hey you know listen i'm not saying i
agree with the the california attorney
general on on a lot of things but they
he gets credit they get credit for at
least
because black lives matter matters
domiciled in california looking into
this as well and i think other states
need to look into it as well so we are
yeah just so people understand this
they're saying that if they don't turn
over these records in california
they're going to hold the leaders of
this organization personally liable
and it's 60 million dollars
where's where's the money
yeah and these facts could lead possibly
to a criminal referral so uh there's
that as well yeah
all right attorney general todd rokita
thank you so much hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else